I went to a little school called Holy
Rosary grade school across from the
Claymont Fire Hall and all my buddies
that came either became a firefighter a
cop or a priest I wouldn't qualify for
your name so here I am but uh
hey what's up everybody I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's October
13 2022 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV if you have not
subscribed do me a favor go ahead and do
it and I've been told by our people the
data people over here at the Reuben
report we've got to add a people believe
it or not that yesterday was our biggest
day across platforms ever across audio
video wherever you're watching yesterday
was the biggest day in Channel History
which is fantastic and the last 28 days
which is how some of these things are
measured have been like by far by far
it's not even close uh our best 28 days
so I'm feeling good this morning things
are good I did change a very poopy
diaper but despite that um here for you
and we got a Big Show and
perhaps more important
than the numbers or the poop but the
message that I have been sharing more
important than the poop that's right the
message that I've been sharing of sort
of this uh you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
the left Has Gone Bananas what would a
sane America look like could we just
revert back to say 15 years ago and
let's get into equality for everybody
and no more Equity no more woke stuff no
more chopping off kids nuts all of that
stuff if we could just do that that we'd
be in good shape well the message seems
to be permeating as you know Tulsi
gabbard yesterday who was the last
Democrat do not forget this as the media
tries to destroy her she was the last
Democrat who stuck around in the
Democrat primary against Joe Biden
everybody else had dropped out cut their
deals to be in the administration or
whatever it might be she is now leaving
the Democrat Party I think the writing
on this one was on the wall for a long
time and it has happened she is not
saying she's a republican but she's on
the way as you know when I had that sit
down just a couple days ago a week or so
ago with Bill Maher he said there are
conditions under with which he could
potentially vote for Iran DeSantis Tulsi
went on Rogan yesterday and they talked
about the shift in all of this so good
stuff is happening uh and of course what
that means is that the machine will put
out the usual suspects to scare the hell
out of you but we are going to insulate
you from the scariness just a few weeks
before Halloween and before we get to
any of that let me talk to you guys
about moink box did you know that 60 of
U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day
there's a better way I want to tell you
guys about moink that's moo plus oink
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door moink Farmers like our moink Farms
more Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result white meat tastes
like it should because the Family Farm
Does It Better the moink difference is
the difference you can taste and you can
feel good knowing you're helping
families Farms stay financially
independent as well you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes or
chicken breasts pork chops salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel anytime my personal favorite is
the filet mignon which I will be cooking
for the family this evening Shark Tank
host Kevin O'Leary called Mike's bacon
the best bacon he's ever had and ring
doorbell founder Jamie simenov jumped at
the chance to invest in moink plus they
guarantee and this is a big one you'll
say oink oink I'm just so happy I got
moyed keep America farming keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time spelled
m-o-i-n-k-box.com
reubenwhitebox.com Reuben okay so let's
let's get to it there is momentum
there really is momentum and in these
moments when we get a little momentum
when some sanity is pilfered out of the
Endless noise we gotta focus on that
sanity and we have to amplify the sanity
so other people go oh my god there are
sane people out there and not everybody
is completely nuts so as you know Tulsi
gabbard has now left the Democrat Party
that is absolutely fantastic uh in her
video explaining it which we showed some
of it yesterday she uh in quite detailed
fashion actually explained why she is
leaving the party and that they've
become anti-American and elitist and
she's had it with the woke stuff and the
neo-racism and the anti-whiteness and
all of that stuff it really in some ways
it felt like a summation of everything
I've been trying to get across over here
so it was really personally it was nice
to me but putting aside me for a moment
uh at a at a sort of societal level or
an American level I think it was really
really fantastic and a message we needed
to hear well she went on Rogan yesterday
uh to talk about sort of where she's at
and then Rogan bonded with where he's at
so I there's there's movement there's
movement happening within
um the Democratic party leadership is
going crazy I think the Republican party
is I don't know they're I think they're
trying to figure out what what they're
doing yeah I mean I think if they had
someone like Ron DeSantis who seems to
be like the most reasonable amongst the
the potential candidates he seems to be
you know a pretty no-nonsense guy not
without his flaws but it he's more
reasonable than anything that I'm seeing
on the left yeah at least with his the
way he handled kovid yeah you know it's
just it's one of those things where
as it's all playing out there's this
sense of hopelessness because there's
not a like a clearly defined path where
this country's ship gets righted it's
like I I just see a lot of chaos and and
a lot of confusion and a lot of
infighting and I don't know how this
plays out
it doesn't it doesn't seem like there's
a real clear oh this is our path to
sanity
okay so first I want to start with what
Rogan was saying there at the end I
actually think there is quite a clear
path now there is a very clean and
straight line path and that is through a
mild Reformation of the Republican party
which is happening right now right with
candidates like JD Vance and Blake
masters with Ron DeSantis sort of being
the steward of this new republicanism
right maybe something uh sort of
adjacent to say an old school Reagan
style republicanism and a desire not to
run your life and inject you with things
and lock you down and all that so it's
interesting that you know Rogan there
I'm giving him credit like he's in
essence he's saying DeSantis is his guy
he's saying it's better than anything on
the left and and clearly he's the
standard Bearer right now of what's
going on on the right or for Republicans
um you know he's saying he's not without
his voice I would love to know what he
thinks those flaws are he's a human
being so of course he's flawed but as a
governor as the chief executive of this
state uh I can surely tell you as a new
Floridian Things Are pretty freaking
fantastic here and we showed you
yesterday the cleanup job that now is
happening with hurricane Ian is beyond
imagination this is something that if
you would have told me 10 days ago they
would have the temporary bridge this
three mile bridge from Fort Myers to
Sanibel Island that was crushed I mean
blown away in certain parts at least
four parts huge huge chunks that within
two weeks they'd be getting trucks going
across they'd have power back on the
island all of these things and Santa was
just one small piece of the devastation
over there it couldn't have happened but
it could happen here in Florida so I I
would love and hopefully and maybe I
think Joe's red pilling is just a little
bit slower I think he will get it again
this is a guy he was a Bernie supporter
uh you know just four so years ago and
then he ultimately ended up leaving
California once he signed a 200 million
dollar deals because he realized oh
there's a lot of taxes over in that
California place so he moved to Texas
right so it's like he's getting there
it's all good it's all good as I said
with Bill Lamarr we can all kind of get
there at different spots I'm gonna keep
poking the bear because that's what I
can do because I I think I got there but
that's that's sort of
that's where he's at and then of course
to tulsi's point it's not the old
Democrat Party anymore and I think for
those of you that are watching this that
have family members that are sane good
people let's let's be clear not every
Democrat is a whack job want to chop off
your kids nuts want to have Equity over
equality uh person right they're they're
just not there are a lot of Democrats
and we all know them who they just
haven't really thought about the issue
seriously they've been bamboozled and
confused by the mainstream media which
lies about everything so again this is
why I do the show the way that I do it
we have to figure out ways to calmly
explain to them uh actually you know it
turns out that those Republicans aren't
really evil it turns out that the
government doesn't have a right to lock
you in your home and and all of that
stuff uh so let's continue here because
there is uh wait we have another Rogan
in Tulsi no okay we're going to go into
the other thing I think we may have a
little something else later there's a
lot of bad news for the Democrats right
now and that's why tulsi's getting ahead
of it I think
um here is an ABC panel discussing what
Republicans will do if the polls are
this close Terry 30 days to the midterms
less than a month ago the Democrats were
feeling pretty hopeful about their
chances do you still get that sense nope
I think the air went out of that balloon
in part because look the economy is so
tough for so many people food prices
rent
spiking if they've got retirement funds
those are evaporating and even the issue
of abortion which did Drive several
special elections and that remarkable
referendum result in Kansas while there
are millions of people for whom that
will be the number one issue I just
think the economic headwinds are so
tough uh and and Biden is he just
doesn't have the oomph as a candidate
anymore people don't really want him
around and he can't really make his case
that I don't think the Democrats are in
any better place and I would also say in
this country and in other countries
polls are broken right it is clear that
lots of people on the right just don't
answer anymore they were worse in 2020
than they were in 2016. and so you look
at those polls it's close if it's close
it's a republican win
that's interesting because you know you
don't get a lot of good analysis
obviously out of mainstream media but
when I led into the clip I said we're
talking about what Republicans will do I
think one thing that Republicans I think
Republicans Republicans conservatives
you guys got it just sort of not the
brainwashed NPC non-playable character
person they're no longer answering polls
uh they also usually only poll by a
landline I haven't had a landline in 10
years probably when's the last time you
guys had a land you got a landline over
there no landline no landline no right
so the polling is just completely out of
whack let's remember the polling was
also completely out of whack right
before uh Trump was elected because a
lot of people didn't want to say that
they they didn't want to actually say
they were going to vote for Trump and
then obviously they did so the reason I
showed you that clip it's like they
still want to frame mainstream always
wants to frame or corporate press always
wants to frame everything through how
can we sort of save the Democrats that's
the idea there but there's Moran
basically being like look the economy is
so banged up Biden doesn't have bump
right like this thing is so screwed up
he tries to sort to save them a little
bit with abortion but I don't know that
the abortion thing is a winner for
Democrats I don't think that eight-month
abortions is a winner I really don't I
think as I went into quite extensively
yesterday I think some moderate position
on that say 15 weeks like many red
states have including here in Florida is
probably the answer and again I actually
read a bunch of comments yesterday a
bunch of you were saying hey there is no
compromise on abortion murder is murder
I respect that personal belief system
and this is what the uh the complex
nature of having a pluralistic society
is all about we got to fit in all of our
religious and spiritual beliefs and
civil beliefs and how do we match that
with the Constitution and all of those
things okay so what are they going to do
as the polls which again it's hard to
make sense of them uh what are they
going to do as the polls don't look
great as P high-profile Democrats leave
as a cultural taste maker like Joe Rogan
is basically like yeah I'm done with you
guys too and I kind of like the DeSantis
guy uh well they're gonna try to scare
the hell out of people here is MSNBC
televised mental institution MSNBC this
is Chris Hayes he looks like a muppet I
don't know maybe he's a muppet maybe
he's a muppet I'm not totally sure uh
saying that the Republicans are going to
destroy the economy to take out the Dems
although I'm pretty sure the Democrats
are in charge right now the midterms
only 27 days away Republicans appear to
think they have the advantage on the
economy big part of that is just that
the party that's out of power uh because
the party that is out of power doesn't
have the White House will typically run
against the status quo and right now a
big part of the status quo is inflation
people don't like it according to the
latest tracking poll the economy is the
number one issue people would like to
hear candidates talk about ahead of
abortion and immigration but if the
economy is the number one issue to
voters then there is one party that will
have an incentive to make it better and
that party is the one that has a
presidency the Democrats the other side
the Republicans have an explicit
incentive to make the economy worse and
I will tell you having covered the Tea
Party Congress of 2011 amidst the
recovery from the financial crisis I
feel confident in predicting that if
Republicans win control of one or both
house of Congress they will do
everything in their power to sabotage
the economy to best set them up to
retake the White House in 2024. that is
such a level of abject nonsense that I
think we would need to add a new level
to the levels that we got okay first off
let me just address the thing with the
tea party there the Tea Party Movement
which of course the mainstream media
called racist and bigot and all that
stuff was about lowering taxes and
states rights and abiding by the
Constitution that's it the media made it
sound like it was a bunch of white
supremacists rallying around crazy Ron
Paul and to take over the country or
something like that they wanted to
actually help the economy by not
spending more than we have just looking
at the books and going hey something
ain't right here can we go back to those
original documents uh the next or the
beginning part of what he says is also
completely out of whack because it is
the Democrats that have destroyed the
economy who is in charge right now he
does at least acknowledge who is in
charge who decided to do the inflation
reduction act now some Republicans voted
for it too which is why it's not like
Republicans are so great which again is
why I always say you you cannot be a
Democrat but you don't have to be a
republic you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
right I'm not saying you have to be a
republican but pretty much you got to
vote for him now so we can get over this
thing and then figure it out after the
idea that somehow the Republicans will
come in and then just make the the
economy that much worse so that a
republican could wield his you know just
you know Rampage through in 2024 is just
nuts and the Republicans don't need to
do it because the Democrats already did
it oh and you might remember we've got a
little compilation for you that there
was a whole series of Democrats
that wanted to lock down the economy and
kick people out of their jobs and make
sure that the machine uh does not work
that you can't go to a job you can't put
food on the table and you'd become more
dependent on the system do we have a
compilation about that we do well hot
diggity dog would you go the route that
Bill Gates is recommending which is
essentially is would you recommend to
Governors at every state to essentially
lock down in order for for a period of
several weeks
for the time being I would yes because
here's the point and you talked about it
last night Anderson you don't know who
doesn't have it the fact that we're
cracking down on people traveling
between homes or planting or landscaping
or golfing really for a couple more
weeks isn't going to meaningfully impact
people's ability to do it because the
snow will do that in and of itself on an
on and off switch but a dimmer switch
facing an unprecedented surge in new
coronavirus cases California governor
Gavin Newsom Wednesday announced the
state was rolling back openings and
reimposing lockdown restrictions in LA
and 18 other counties representing over
70 percent of the state's population
Newsome will close indoor operations of
restaurants bars movie theaters Wineries
and zoos for at least three weeks we
also have to be clear on who was
responsible for each element of the
opening the president said last night
that he has totally Authority
for
determining how and when States reopen
that is not an accurate statement
but I don't regret saying that the only
way we could have really stopped the
explosion of infection was by
essentially I want to say shutting down
I mean essentially having the physical
separation and the kinds of
recommendations that we've made you've
been a big fan of Cuomo and the shutdown
of New York you've lauded New York for
their policy New York had the highest
death rate in the world how could we
possibly be jumping up and down and
saying oh Governor Cuomo did a great job
he had the worst death rate in the world
all right I assure you guys we could
have shown you a much longer compilation
of that but you have lives you're
functioning people you have things to do
we don't want to belabor the point you
get it these were all Democrats the few
bastions of freedom for those two years
were Republican run States like Florida
and South Dakota and Texas Tennessee
etc etc so who destroyed the economy as
Chris Hayes is talking about the economy
it not only is it the people who lock
down and also remember uh Donald Trump
was president during the beginning of
kovid they were calling him Hitler and
then they were also saying that he
should use federal authority to lock
everybody down so they wanted Hitler to
have more power and the reason that they
can make that jump so easily is they
only care about power the left is only
based on how can we attain and exercise
power that's it it has nothing to do
with individual rights or Freedom or
anything else like that so it was the
Democrats who destroyed the economy on
top of the ridiculous last two years of
what we've done to energy and supply
chain and the inflation reduction act
which was just spending more money that
actually increased inflation and
everything else oh and hot damn we did
it again you guys are on fire today
here's video of Chris Hayes calling for
lockdowns as the coronavirus continues
to devastate this country I am just
finding it hard to hold my rage and my
anguish together
we are watching a lack of action by the
federal leadership of this country that
feels
almost criminal no country on Earth that
has successfully suppressed the
coronavirus in a distributed privatized
federalized way
nowhere on Earth where the government
just told localities and individuals to
make choices for themselves
that didn't work for anyone
in fact it's the opposite that's been
successful look at Australia they also
adopted really strict measures
Australia even stopped people traveling
between provinces completely country
undertook a fully nationalized effort to
suppress the virus and it was strict and
it was hard and you know what it worked
we just cannot forget we just cannot
forget what these people did and as
always guys that's why they want to
censor people that's why they want to
Shadow ban people that's why they want
to be the Arbiters of what's
misinformation or not he's lauding
Australia which had the most Draconian
lockdowns maybe in the west perhaps
Canada had a little bit more I would say
Canada probably had a little bit more
um but he he's and there he's at the
same time he's doing that you see he's
showing you a picture of trump the man
he has run around calling Hitler in a
white supremacist and all and he's
saying that Hitler is not doing enough
Hitler what are you doing Hitler can you
just get out there and exert more
control over us Hitler because that's
what everybody wanted in World War II
just Insanity uh here is Anthony fauci
yesterday apparently Chris Cuomo from
CNN you saw his brother Andrew Cuomo
there the disgraced former governor of
New York although everything being equal
he was a hell of a lot better than this
crazy woman Kathy Ocho well he got
booted from New York and Chris Cuomo got
booted from CNN but these people keep
appearing like weeds you can't stop them
so fauci went on Cuomo's show and
finally cuovo who was all for lockdown's
hiding information about his brother and
the the nursing homes and all that stuff
suddenly now he's independent so now
he's he's getting some balls but if you
treated people more as adults Tony sorry
to interrupt but have you treated people
more as adults I mean like look
we don't know 100 I think it's better if
you have a mask
um it's better if you keep some distance
but I don't really know uh if we had
treated people like adults
and giving them the information as
qualified like you guys do about
everything else in our medical lives
nobody gives you 100 of anything
everything's percentages
don't you think maybe we would have
avoided the lockdowns that we would have
avoided some of the more Extreme
Measures because people would have been
told all along listen this is a you know
this is a dicey proposition we don't
really know about these things
I have to disagree with You Chris I love
you but I got to disagree with you go
ahead of course
the fact is that
by saying you don't know doesn't really
change whether or not you're going to
lock down lockdowns got a bad reputation
but remember when we put a pause on
things for 15 days and then an
additional 30 days it was out of time
when the hospital system in New York was
being overrun and the only way you stop
that is by essentially stopping the
virus in its tracks you can do that by
locking down but lockdown has to be the
last resort and it can never be
permanent
okay so there's so much nonsense there
and fauci probably should end up in jail
if there is Justice here uh first off
when the hospital systems in New York
were being overrun where is the video
anywhere in the world of hospitals that
were overrun with deaths nowhere in
Africa where maybe their clean water
isn't as clean uh where that you know
somewhere in Eastern Europe where their
practices are a little bit different
than ours where are any of the hospitals
where's one city in the United States
where's the back uh the back water place
in Alabama that they're just really
backwards rednecks according to these
people that didn't clean their hands and
everything else where the whole town was
taken out why is there no video of that
anywhere and then at the end that he
dare he dare say the last option is
lockdowns that was the first option for
them remember two weeks to slow the
spread that was the first thing they
decided and the vaccines didn't work and
the lockdowns didn't work and The Masks
didn't work fauci had the gall you may
remember this just two or three months
into this thing when he's demanding
everyone masking literally on air he's
talking about double masking a friend of
his asks us emails him these emails have
come out a friend of him asked I think
they were going to Mexico do the kids
have to wear masks and he says they
basically don't work because you know
mask when you put a mask on you're still
getting air this way and air this way
and all of this stuff so everything he
says is a lie and he's just trying to
save his ass now and yes he did somehow
get five million dollars richer over the
last two years that's pretty good isn't
it uh he did manage to do that and have
the largest highest salary as a federal
employee and the highest pension as a
federal employee
um but it's not that the Democrats are
just killing the economy because of
locking people down and we're just
seeing the repercussions of those two
years it's because the energy policies
right now are absolutely horrible
but don't take my word for it yeah I'm
just some crazy right-wing YouTube guy
talk to uh or listened to uh former
Obama economic advisor Larry Summers
talking about what Biden is doing we are
paid more
to Dangerously ship
oil and natural gas
on trucks
because the ability to cite pipelines is
being held up
we are burning more coal
because permits to frack and get Natural
Gas
aren't being granted
uh that's an Obama guy I'm pretty sure
Obama's in charge of Biden so what in
the hell is going on here you know
that's not some crazy right-winger on
Fox Business that is an Obama Guy saying
Biden you and your policies you are the
ones doing this do we have the numbers
on the the debt because I put up a lot
of zeros on the street could we do we
got the number yeah here's the U.S debt
Clock uh today's national U.S debt uh
it's over 31 trillion dollars that's
three one one four zero zero zero two oh
four seven two six three
although we did this we put this
together about you know 20 minutes ago
so it's higher than that right now uh
the point is these people are spending
like drunken Sailors who's spend an
awful lot but there are and their Hooks
and all the stuff that they've got you
know uh how much did Joe Biden spend
this year to fix the thing that he
actually made worse well we've got some
info from USA facts the federal
government spent 6.8 trillion in 2021 or
just about twenty thousand dollars per
person it's funny that they don't give
you that twenty thousand dollars right
or they don't let you keep your twenty
thousand dollars they always take it and
somehow figure out a way to do something
with your 20 grand the federal
government spends 68 percent more than
it collected in 2021 resulting in a 2.8
trillion dollar deficit uh let me just
address that for a second because people
are always confused by this because the
Democrats then run around Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden and Obama and all
them they'd run around saying it's
because we're not getting enough money
it's those rich people people and the
one percenters they're avoiding taxes
even though they pay more taxes than
everybody if you're in the bottom third
you don't pay any taxes basically people
in the one percent which also the one
percent thing is a total misnomer you're
in the one percent at about 400 Grand a
year
I know most people would love to be
making 400 Grand per year but that is
not Ultra Ultra ultra wealthy obviously
right yes you're doing just fine if
you're making 400 Grand per year
um but it is not a revenue issue it's a
spending issue there is no amount of
money that you could give the government
where the government would be like oh
we're good guys uh you know what uh well
we do have enough and but we've got a
little extra actually and we're going to
give some of it back to you no it does
not exist the government operates in a
way that it is a giant sucking machine
just Google sucking and see what comes
up no don't Google sucking and see what
comes up okay don't do that but the
point is the government just wants more
and more and more there is never enough
if you took all of the billionaires
money it would still not be enough so
how much have we spent so far in 2022
because I was giving you the 2021
numbers well we've got data from the
fiscal data Treasury uh the U.S
government has spent 5.35 trillion in
fiscal year 2022 to ensure the
well-being of the people of the United
States
are you guys getting it yet the well
they've spent 5.35 trillion that's a lot
of dough you got 5.35 trillion what am I
paying you people the point is guys
there's no amount that you can give them
or that they can steal from you that
would be enough and then when they do
that stuff do you feel like it really
worked so they did this giant inflation
reduction act do you feel like things
are much better
is anything across the board much better
did prices go down on certain things
um do you have more money in your pocket
etc
etc
etc but let's go back to that Muppet
Chris Hayes guy because maybe this isn't
only about how Republican candidates are
out there to destroy the world and be
mean and be racist and wreck the economy
maybe it is a little something to do
with the people that are in office right
now the Democrats who were running
things and the people that they are
trying to bring in for the next couple
years uh here is video of John fetterman
who is a Pennsylvania Senate candidate
running against Dr Oz and uh well just
watch Eagles
are so much better
than Eagles at first I just wanted to
check in and see how how you're feeling
and how you're doing
I'm doing fine I'm doing fantastic and
and uh it's not about kicking balls in
the Authority or anything and make sure
you take advantage of this amazing
opportunity to the only thing you have
stand to lose is your record what is
wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their income
a path to a safe place for them to win
and I can Champion the union way of life
in Jersey and excuse me in DC if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stand with you in DC
uh that guy is basically neck and neck
with Dr Oz right now now I do want to be
clear about one thing he had a stroke a
couple months ago I am not belittling in
any way the the repercussions of the
stroke this is to illustrate should this
person be running for office we already
know what's going on with Biden there is
something wrong there do we need more of
this on top of the fact that he's always
wearing the hoodie he doesn't come off
as professional at all he also his his
litany if you were just to look at the
list of stuff that he's into this guy
wants to put all the criminals back out
on the streets he wants every every
Equity based nonsense policy of the
progressives is what this guy wants but
for some reason the machine is pushing
him over and over and over and over uh
here's video this is from uh just about
two days ago I think of fetterman
talking about his stroke his campaign
required that he'd be allowed to use a
transcription program on his computer
during our interview I always thought I
was pretty empathetic uh emphatic
I think I was very excuse me empathetic
uh you know that's an example of stroke
empathetic I always thought I was very
empathetic before having a stroke but
now after having that stroke I really
understand you know much more kind of
the challenges that Americans have
okay so again I am not making fun of
anyone for having a stroke my dad had a
very severe stroke 25 years ago thank
God he's okay
um so that it's not about that is the
point is should this guy with whatever
is going on with him put aside the bad
policy so you have all the bad policies
that's just standard Democrat stuff at
this point but should this person be in
the U.S Senate it doesn't really seem
like he should you know what's
interesting about that so he was getting
the transcription on the computer now
the transcription just meant that her
words were being translated so he could
read them so I don't even know what he
was reading as he was all confused there
it's it's a real mess but here once
again you see how the machine protects
certain people with certain points of
view so the machine is protecting him
just because they don't want Dr Oz at Dr
Oz by the way is no like standard bearer
of republicanism I mean he's sort of a
lukewarm moderate I think the guy's
pretty decent actually uh but like it's
not like he's some you can't say that's
a crazy Maga far-right Republican but
the machine obviously wants veteran more
than him so they will do everything they
can to sort of make you not see what you
can see right in front of your eyes
here's CNN's Dr Sanjay Gupta basically
explaining what's going on with veteran
to kind of make people feel more okay
with it listening to him he sounded like
he was fairly fluent in a speech able to
speak pretty clearly every now and then
he would have a little word sort of mash
up as he calls it but what's interesting
let me show you here something um The
Stroke which was on May 13th so about
five months ago seemed to affect his
ability to sort of comprehend or
understand spoken speech so what he
seems to be doing then is then sort of
relying more on his visual part of his
brain which is back here to read the
words and then he's responding pretty
quickly okay again not making fun of the
stroke but you see their running cover
for him this is the guy that they want
so they're going to bring out the brain
and he's using this and not using this
and it's okay and it was just a couple
words and sometimes he doesn't know
where he is or what state he's in
okay do you think they would be doing
that or that they did that when Remember
When Donald Trump drank a glass of water
with two hands
now look I just for the record
wow vodka this early in the morning huh
uh but remember that Donald Trump once
drank water with two hands like this
half of blue check Twitter and
mainstream media was calling for the
25th amendment that he was not fit to
serve do you think Sanjay Gupta would
have got up there and been like Trump is
okay they they were constantly calling
for his impeachment saying that he was
unfit for office all of that stuff so
I'm just showing you how the how the The
Jig Is up it's like we see it guys we
see it and if you really want to see how
The Jig Is up this was the first video
that I I saw this morning this is so
incredible that you just gotta get get
comfortable in your seat everybody just
kind of like chill out for a moment this
is so absolutely wonderful this is video
from yesterday AOC did a town hall in
the Bronx in her home district and
you'll see basically nobody showed up
and the few people that did were not
having it with her nonsense
congresswoman none of this matters
unless there's a nuclear war which you
voted to send arms and weapons to
Ukraine Tulsi gathers she's left the
Democratic party
okay you originally voted you ran as an
outsider yet you've been voting to start
this war in Ukraine you're voting to
start a sermon nuclear war with Russia
and China why are you playing with the
lies of American citizens you're playing
with our lives there will be no
neighbors if there's a nuclear bomb you
voted to mobilize and send money to
Ukrainian Nazis you're a coward you're a
progressive socialist where are you
against the war mobilization he's
telling the right truth you have done
nothing Tulsi gabbard has shown guts
where you've shown cowardice I believed
in you and you became the very thing you
sought to fought against that's what
you've become sir you are the
establishment and you are the reason why
everybody will end up in a nuclear war
unless you choose to stand up right now
and denounce the Democratic party will
you do that
yes or no
today is a great day I mean that is so
beautiful now first let me address a
couple things uh I don't know maybe 30
people in there right so nobody in her
own district is listening to her anymore
the squad and I've been trying to
explain this from the beginning the
squad was a corporate idea and a big
Tech idea the average person doesn't
want their kids genitals chopped off the
average kid doesn't want their child the
average adult doesn't want their kid
dying in Ukraine and all of the other
equity-based nonsense and all of the
drivel the and the hatred of America and
all that stuff that AOC and Omar and
Talib have put out there so they don't
really have support yes she has won two
elections I I give her credit for that
in a very small District she won these
two elections so it's not like there's
literally nobody but it certainly is not
as big as the machine would have you
believe put her on every cover of
everything and constantly put her on the
Sunday news shows and everything else
the young people that are yelling at her
there are quite right I thought the
progressives weren't the progressives
supposed to be nice and anti-war why
would we be giving
all this money and weapons and again we
haven't declared war to the ukrainians
when we're not exactly sure who they are
and there are some Nazi elements there
and it's all very strange and suddenly
the more that this keeps going on the
more that we're suddenly talking about
nuclear war and World War III I thought
the progressives were supposed to be out
there screaming uh against War but
that's not really what they're about
when they're in power is it uh what's
really beautiful about that is aoc's
response to that guy basically was
you're being rude so I don't have to
respond to you this is the same AOC who
repeatedly has done what Maxine Waters
has done and many other progressives
which is you get up in their face and
you show up at their events and you
don't give them any quarter and all of
those things so AOC you have opened up a
Pandora's Box baby and it's on you now
so good luck the inmates are running the
Asylum and uh they're going to have you
for lunch
so let's go full circle here people what
do you do well you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
who is the guy that came up with that
that's good man we got to Google that uh
here is Tulsi on Rogan again explaining
how the Democrats are ruining America
the Democratic party that I joined
doesn't exist anymore the party that was
um you know the party of JFK of Dr
Martin Luther King the party of
inclusivity the big tent party that
welcomed and encouraged this Marketplace
of ideas and conversations and people
who held different views the party of uh
you know the championed women and
equality and the rights of people in our
society that party just it doesn't exist
anymore and instead we have a party
that's being led by by people who have
gone insane with this ideological uh
fanaticism and there are a lot of
different issues a lot of different
examples you know the whole issue of of
uh biology and uh the trans issue is
just one of them there are so many
different others you know parents don't
have you don't have a right to raise
your kids now you don't have a right to
say what they're being taught in schools
now the state the government the the
teachers unions only they have that
right and responsibility they're
undermining families they don't believe
in the rule of laws yeah defund the
police the Supreme in court we don't
agree with them so they're illegitimate
guys that's the chick that's leaving the
party right it's like if she was there
like I think I could turn these guys
around they're listening and they're
good decent people and I enjoy being
with them
maybe more sane centrists would be going
in that direction but that is not what's
happening of course Tulsi is right about
all of those things and and to briefly
mention the two people of course that
she brought up at top JFK JFK John F
Kennedy who is a Democrat asked not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country that is the
polar opposite 180 degree opposite of
the modern Democrat Party the modern
Democrat Party says the government must
take from you and then somehow give you
some stuff back if Bernie Sanders was to
say that on stage they would Lynch him
and they'll probably Lynch him anyway
because you can sense that the lynching
I mean this uh metaphorically like
they're coming after them now because
they're realizing that the progressives
who purported to be all of these nice
things that they're not they're actually
for war and there are four more
government money and all of these things
so they'll take out AOC and they'll take
out Bernie and they'll take out
everybody the Bernie one was obvious
from way back when like at the end of
the day he was always going to turn into
an old white guy and that's all that he
is
um it's an old white socialist is there
anything more terrible can you imagine
just having dinner with an old white
socialist I don't mean it white like I
don't get rid of the skin color there's
an old bitter socialist okay like no uh
anyway uh that was JFK and then of
course she also mentions Martin Luther
King Jr and Martin Luther King Jr what
did he want for his children I think he
wanted them not to be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character well is that what the
Democrat Party of 2022 wants no of
course it's the complete reverse you are
allowed to burn down certain cities if
that fits in with your political
ideology we are going to have
equity-based hiring we are going to hire
people based on the color of their skin
or whether or not they chopped off their
genitals or what gender they are and
everything else so she's making a lot of
sense speaking of sense we got a little
more from her is they don't believe in
freedom of speech they don't believe in
Freedom of thought they don't believe in
freedom of religion all they believe in
is you've got to buy into whatever
they're selling at any given day and and
like I said not only it's not enough to
agree you've got to go out there you've
got to march in the parade you've got to
carry the sign you've got to scream and
yell and don't you dare even think about
talking to Republicans don't don't even
think about working with Republicans
because that that directly undermines
their their Authority
sound familiar sound familiar from some
guy that faced six seven years ago was a
lefty who kept saying hey there's
problems here guys I'm gonna go talk to
some Republicans I'm going to talk to
some conservatives and see what they're
like and then it turns out that they're
not actually like what the machine wants
you to believe that they are like does
that sound a little bit familiar yeah it
kind of gets kind of ringing crew to me
it's weird how that's happening what's
also interesting about what she said
right there you know we showed you the
clip and if you haven't watched the full
Club random with Bill Maher uh please do
it's two hours but I promise you you'll
dig it and we do a lot and I know there
are moments that you some of you thought
that he was like a little too jokey with
me instead of focusing on whatever it's
all good we have a friendship out of it
to start building some of these Bridges
as Tulsi and Rogan are trying to do but
if you caught that piece we should we
shared a clip on social media at the end
where I say to Bill hey you know Bill
you know you could have always shown up
to a trump rally and a certain amount of
people there would have been like
Fillmore and he whatever okay but an
awful lot of people would have been like
Bill Maher's here that's pretty goal is
he on his way is he getting red pilled
and that really is true people that
really is true he could have shown up to
any one of those things I am not a
traditional Republican and I would show
up to those things and be treated like a
freaking King okay but what would happen
to Bill Maher as I said to him if he
showed up to an AOC rally he would be
exactly what Tulsi just said you have to
believe what they believe the second
they believe it or you are out so now
Tulsi gets it Rogan's getting it more
and more people are getting it Mar is
starting to get get it
and I think that really does lead us to
this brighter future the future on the
other side of this thing when we've
looked when this is all just but a
distant memory and we're like oh we've
completely put that woke [ __ ] behind us
and that racist [ __ ] behind us we
stopped letting children pretend that
they're adults we stop chopping off
genitals all of the stuff
a little more from Tulsi so I'm I'm I'm
leaving the Democratic party is that
this big announcement yeah you're
leaving the demo I'm leaving the
Democratic party because
I've tried to enact that change from
within
it's not I I I don't see the Democratic
party as being savable
and I know that I can make an impact uh
more from the outside and frankly I just
I can't be associated in standby uh this
this Insanity that's been going on and
continues to worsen day by day are you
going to be an independent yep
so this is not for trying that's her
that she didn't try right that's her
point it's not that she did not try she
did try she was a member of Congress
serving with the squad she tried to talk
some sense into them she tried to talk
some sense into the leadership and what
did she get for it she got Hillary
Clinton literally calling her a Russian
asset so if that's what a Russian asset
sounds like I guess we're all Russian
assets if you're saying you're a Russian
asset congratulations
one more time Guys somebody once said
you don't have to be a republican but
you cannot be a Democrat got to put that
on a bumper sticker uh stick around for
a cold close and a couple comments from
the reubenreport.locals.com community EK
says my baby finally noticed Dave on the
TV and stopped crying I I am a wizard at
getting babies to stop crying something
good is going on there I think it's
partly because I'm I'm doing all this
stuff during the day right so I'm in and
out of the studio I'm bouncing around so
David's down there with the kids kids
are crying and then I just come in and
I'm like hey how you doing what's going
on I Lift You Up Lift It Out who can't
see me and so the kids are always
smiling when I'm around it's it's tough
I think they David said they call this
the pickle jar Theory or something that
the woman usually is always in the
kitchen and she can't get the pickle jar
open you know about this but then so
then she asked the man to come in and
the man's just like yep right there
because she was working it the whole
time I think we're having a degree of
that around here Kathy says La is like a
different country at this point yeah
I have no desire to go back I told Mar
I'll go back to play basketball with him
but I have no desire otherwise to go
back remember so when uh the little
sidebar but when we went back a couple
weeks ago for the mar thing and I did
some stuff for prageru Phoenix and I are
having lunch at uh panco de end did I
pronounce that correctly and we have our
bags with us because we're traveling we
hadn't hit the hotel yet and we walk
into the place the server or the the
host basically I opened the door the
server sees that we have bags and he's
like where are you guys coming from and
I was like I was like Florida and he's
like oh I'll try not to say anything bad
about Florida and I without a hesitation
I was like well I'll try not to say
anything bad about LA and then we didn't
see him again right he didn't he never
came back to the table that that's
what's going on over there uh Jeannie
says people are completely blind to the
environmental damage done by
environmental laws especially younger
people they've been indoctrinated and
taught to fear fossil fuels by the
education system yeah that's not exactly
what we were talking about today but I
would recommend any of you go to human
progress us.org and find out what really
is going on with the environment and and
this myopic view that if we only could
wreck our economy in the name of saving
the environment that we could stop
climate change which has always been
going on or that somehow if these people
just had enough money that the United
States would be able to leave the world
on this while other countries India
China Etc are going to still go through
their industrial revolutions and they
need fossil fuels perhaps in ways that
we don't anymore and what right would we
have to tell them not to do it
you got it you got it uh guys do me a
favor despite the fact that yesterday
was our best day ever and this month has
been our best month ever uh we'd still
like you to like And subscribe what's
that two days two days ago was yesterday
it was two days ago was our best day
ever thank you for not letting me get
away with that one really you guys
guacamole on me two days ago was our
best day ever I would assume yesterday
went pretty well anyway uh rumble.com
Ruben report rubinreport.com locals uh
have a great day everybody and we leave
you with the elderly man pretending to
be president
and we did and by the way I'm not sure I
would have understood how important this
was has I not gotten to see these see
these Parks until I understood the
breathtaking nature of it to stand there
on the edge of a cliff in the Rio Grande
to you know look at that one thing and
it's just there's not many Cliffs but
then head up to the uh the Grand Canyon
it's a cathedral I mean it takes your
breath away I've climbed it from the
river up and I've looked at it from the
from the top down